Buckingham Palace says the queen consort
has tested positive for covid our
correspondent Aisha zahid joins me now
on set so we obviously knew that there
was an unconfirmed illness leading to
not having not being able to to go to an
engagement tomorrow but but learning
just just moments ago it's covered
that's right earlier this afternoon
Buckingham Palace had said that the
queen consort Camilla had contracted a
seasonal illness we now know she has
tested positive for covid-19 and Rural
sources have told Sky News that she is
in good spirit she's resting and if
anything she's disappointed that she
won't be able to make the engagements
that were in the diary for this week of
course it was a busy week for the queen
consort you on Wednesday was going to be
holding a reception in Clarence House
for authors to celebrate the second
anniversary of her book club on Thursday
she was due to visit Milton Keynes with
King Charles in order to celebrate their
City status all of that will have to be
postponed now and of course we we saw
her last weekend of last week on the 9th
of February the Thursday at a charity in
Battersea a charity which supports
domestic abuse survivors so she has had
a busy few weeks the the real thing
she'll need to focus on now is resting
up and she hopes to feel better for
engagements in the coming weeks however
Buckingham Palace say that announcement
on engagements taking place next week
will be confirmed in due course whether
or not they will go ahead or not and I
presume given you haven't mentioned it
the palace haven't said anything about
the the king and that no news is good
news in that regard yes we hope no news
is good news on that regard nothing
about King Charles as of yet
um like I say Royal sources have said
though queen queen consort Camilla is in
good spirit she's resting and if
anything just disappointed that these
engagements can't go ahead this week